life requires us to be very sane pretty
much all the time on a daily basis we
have to be responsible polite productive
thoughtful patient logical reliable and
dazzlingly successful to these
obligations slowly crept up on us as we
were growing up now they are our
constant realities the problem is no one
can really keep going like this over a
whole lifetime the burdens are too great
our minds too delicate unfortunately
society doesn't give us much room to
fall apart it wants us at the desk 9:00
a.m. sharp every day with a PowerPoint
ready to go and the pressure doesn't let
up till we've finally released a sleep
past 11:00 at night so we have no option
but to keep going while on the side we
may well be drinking too much waking up
at odd times of night addicted to the
internet calming ourselves down with
sedatives and developing all kinds of
physical twitches and ailments but in
truth no good life can or should go by
without a few quite open incidents of
complete breakdown moments when we pull
up a white flag and declare ourselves
simply unable to cope or fulfill any of
our normal functions for a time rather
than seeing this as an illness this
should be interpreted as evidence of
normality and even health during our
crazy moments we might be lying in bed
staring at the ceiling for long periods
seeming to make no sense
wearing strange clothes and sitting on
the porch all day doing nothing shouting
singing dancing cavorting being silly in
a way one hasn't been for decades making
some unusual new friends and taking off
to strange places naturally such phases
won't be easy for those around us but we
should collectively know how to tolerate
these phases without panic as just part
of ordinary life we allow our bodies to
have moments of breakdown and rest
we should allow similar moments for our
minds in any case the so-called sane
world is pretty disturbed too once one
considers it frankly
apparently mental health that we set
ourselves the task of energetically
destroying the planet work to meet
punishing but arbitrary economic targets
leave ourselves no time for anything but
work drown in toxic media and develop
unrealistic expectations about our
bodies relationships and families no
wonder we need periods of true madness
as a corrective that said the emphasis
should always be on having a good mental
breakdown a good one is where we allow
ourselves to reconnect with valuable
truths that we've lost sight of emotions
and insights that ordinary life has
prevented us from investigating perhaps
sexual exploration creativity
heedlessness contact with our bodies
empathy ecstasy or a new kind of
self-knowledge the idea is that we
should return from the land of madness
and plant in the fields of apparent
sanity a lot of pretty valuable seeds
that can bear fruit and sustain us in
the periods ahead we should at a
collective level give ourselves unfried
endure Kant saw what mad episodes mean
confident that a reconciliation with the
demands of the world will eventually
reemerge we are not automatons but
highly complicated volatile collections
of proteins that needs careful and
sympathetic administration we should
expect that periods of madness just do
belong to every wise and good life
you